why
so as we pick up with Deadpool kills the
Marvel Universe part three what we're
going to find is that Deadpool is not
arbitrarily killing superheroes and
supervillains that Deadpool actually has
an underlying motivation here not only
that Deadpool has become aware of
something that nobody else is aware of
that nobody else seems to know and what
we'll see as we progress to this comic
is that some individuals will discover
what it is that Deadpool knows but
they'll discover it at the cost of
either their own sanity or the result of
their or I guess the cost of their own
lives but what we'll also do in this
story is we're going to bounce back and
forth between Deadpool and taskmaster
now it's not going to be a direct
confrontation in fact it's going to be
taskmaster as he's tracking down
Deadpool and we'll also I guess jump
into Deadpool as he is going about or
continuing his goal of the end result
that he set for himself but as we start
this story we pick up with taskmaster as
he's tracking down Deadpool of course we
see that the taskmaster has been
tracking Deadpool for several days we of
course see that venom has been killed by
Deadpool he's strung about a bell tower
and it seems as though Deadpool is most
likely used the reverberating sound of a
bell to presumably kill venom we exactly
don't know how it was that this happened
but we also see that Deadpool has killed
both Jaimie madrix and the Green Goblin
but one of the interesting things here
is that taskmaster arrives at a scene
where it appears that Deadpool had
killed the powerpack and what a
taskmaster tells us is that even he
despite the fact that he's a villain has
his own code of conduct has his own
moral code even if it does cause him to
come into conflict with superheroes but
the moral code that he has and most
likely the moral code of virtually all
supervillains with the exception of the
most insane is that they don't kill kids
and so the fact that Deadpool they
killed the powerpack indicates that he's
beyond any chance of redemption and so
as taskmaster tells us that if there was
any question of the fact that Deadpool
should die that question has been
removed from the equation and so there's
really no alternative accepted killed
Deadpool from here we pick up with
Deadpool
he's captured Professor Charles Xavier
then what he does is tell Charles Xavier
wake up indicating that he's maybe held
Charles Xavier for quite some time and
what we also know is that it seems as
though maybe the x-men are hunting for
Charles Xavier but we don't exactly know
where they're at at this point in time
but what uh what Deadpool tells Charles
Xavier is that he can sleep when he's
dead and then it won't be that long
before he's dead anyway of course
telling us that Deadpool intends to kill
Charles Xavier relatively soon and of
course once Charles Xavier comes to he
begins to question Deadpool and he asked
Deadpool what it is that he wants what
it is that he's doing and that he's
heard so many people and this is when
Deadpool begins to touch on the idea
that he knows something that nobody else
knows and what he tells Charles Xavier
is that no one really feels anything
they don't really feel anything
that for him it doesn't really matter if
any of them die because in the end it
doesn't matter that there's really no
purpose in any of them existing now of
course this seems to be the insane
ramblings of a Deadpool but as we'll
learn later on there's actually a method
there's a I guess sanity behind this
claim that he's making but what he does
is he stabs Charles Xavier and a leg and
then tells Charles Xavier to say
something and so what Charles Xavier
does is he calls the x-men he calls the
x-men to his location to the building
that he's in and so from here we
switched to Emma Frost Cyclops to
cannonball and a pixie and what we do is
we see that almost immediately after
they arrived that Cyclops is I guess his
head is encased and some kind of a
gelatinous material or at the very least
it seems gelatinous but as Emma Frost
explains it to us that the material what
it started off as a as a gelatinous
material had begun to solidify and then
it's something that just won't come off
the head of of Cyclops she says that her
concern here is the Cyclops won't be
able to breathe as fast as his hardening
and so what Cyclops does as he begins to
try to blast the material off of his
head using its optic beam but for
Cyclops the problem here is that this
material is a solid to the point where
it can withstand the object beams of
Cyclops
and so what happens is that as the
energy from Cyclops as optic beams build
up inside of this this case that it
ultimately explodes and when it does it
blows up in the same fashion
bomb which kills uh which kills
cannonball Emma Frost Cyclops and of
course pixie and so we transition back
to Deadpool and Charles Xavier and
Deadpool again makes a comment with
regards to a lot of the fans of the
x-men and ask the question of why it was
that Charles Xavier had always felt the
need to continually expand the roster of
the x-men why it is that he couldn't
simply just stick with a small group of
people but what we also see is that
Deadpool transitions or I guess shows
Charles Xavier what's going on with
Colossus gambit and rogue and of course
we see gambit telling us that that
they've been in the worst spots and
they're in right now that this entire
building seems to be some kind of
deathtrap but they'll find a way out but
before they're able to move any further
all three of them are electrocuted
they're totally incinerated and we
switch back to Deadpool and Charles
Xavier and Charles Xavier and what
Deadpool says here is that he doesn't
think he'll be getting his security
deposit back because it'll be so
incredibly hard to clean out the stench
of electrocuted mutant and so from this
point we see the third voice of Deadpool
come into play again as Charles Xavier
begins to address Deadpool once more and
the third voice on Deadpool's head tells
him the Charles Xavier wants to talk now
it has never been very easy for Charles
Xavier to read the mind of Deadpool and
that hopefully somehow Charles Xavier
will attempt to connect with Deadpool
and that Deadpool should let him do that
and so what we see is Deadpool
continuing to converse with Charles
Xavier and again touching on what it is
that he thinks he knows or believes that
he knows as far as something that nobody
else is aware of and what he says is
that everybody had thought that he was
crazy everybody thought that he was
insane because he broke the fourth wall
because he talked to talk to basically
the audience as far as his communication
in the comic books but what he says is
that once psycho man had entered his
head that he began to see everything
clearly he began to understand exactly
where he stood and what all was going on
here but again he doesn't go in-depth
into what it is that he knows he doesn't
go in-depth and telling us exactly what
it is if he's figured out what just kind
of left to guess at this point in time
but what we see is a Charles Xavier
tells Deadpool that he's had enough and
he's not going to let Deadpool kill
anybody else and he's going to shut his
mind
down and this is when we see Charles
Xavier actually entering the mind of
Deadpool and when he does he realizes
what it is a Deadpool knows and it is up
costing the life of Charles Xavier when
he goes into a catatonic state when his
brain shuts down and so from here we see
that Deadpool gives us the an
explanation of sorts involving some of
the other characters in the x-men
villains and superheroes alike and of
course we learned that magneto had been
killed by deadpool when he was i guess
he is in a room or in some kind of a
case that's filled with an acidic jelly
which of course is eaten away at the
body of magneto and killed him
but what we also see is that Kitty Pryde
is stuck in some kind of weird physics
experiment which of course Deadpool
tells us he doesn't understand much
about physics or tesseract but that it
seems as though whatever this cage is in
that Kitty Pryde is trapped him and
she's not going to be able to escape
that she's going to be effectively stuck
in this thing forever and so from here
we see that Wolverine has arrived' that
he apparently survived the explosion at
Avengers mansion and has come looking
for Deadpool and as Wolverine is making
his way through the building he comes
across arcade and of course arcade is a
villain who has a big part of the x-men
history albeit in a smaller scale but he
was a character who would constantly
made all different kinds of death traps
and an effort to kill the x-men and so
when he realizes Wolverines there he
tells Wolverine he has to get him out of
there
that Deadpool is totally insane that
Deadpool has started forcing arcade to
make all different kinds of death traps
and devices that are totally out of this
world that are things that arcade
himself would have never dreamed of
simply because it was too extreme but
what Wolverine says is that every single
time he's ever come into contact with
arcade that arcade has always tried to
kill Wolverine and the x-men and so
Wolverine is not going to rescue arcade
and instead he's simply just going to
killed him and so from here after arcade
is presumably left for his own death we
pick up with bacon and x-23 and what
Wolverine is told by Deadpool as
Deadpool arrives behind Wolverine is
that the healing factors of of Daken and
x-23 were something that were difficult
to deal with and so Deadpool dealt with
their healing factors in the same way
that he would deal with his own and what
he's done
here is he has them hooked up to
flamethrowers and computer monitors and
the flamethrowers of course are
constantly burning their bodies but they
stop after a time and what the
flamethrowers do is they reactivate
whenever the computer detects that the
healing factors of bacon and x-23 are
coming back into play again but from
here we transition to Deadpool as he's
officially confronting Wolverine and
Deadpool is apparently wearing the pelt
of Beast he's taken beast and and
stripped him of his skin of his fur and
is wearing it as he's a fighting against
Wolverine and of course what he tells
Wolverine here is that he's a hunter
that he feels like a hunter with the
garbha T's wearing that he's a samurai
mountain man and of course a Wolverine
is not having any of the guff that that
a Deadpool of spewing here and so again
as the two of them begin to engage in
conflict
Deadpool tells a tells Wolverine that
he's wielding a carbonadium sword and
that while while rain does have a
healing factor that the carbonadium
sword basically wreaks havoc
it keeps Wolverines healing factor from
being able to to manifest it keeps him
from being able to heal from his wounds
and so again we see the Deadpool starts
to tear into Wolverine starts to attack
him once more but what Deadpool also
says here is that Wolverines mutant
power is not his healing factor it's
this popularity is the fact that he
doesn't die due to his healing factor
it's the fact that he doesn't die
because people that write him don't want
him to die and what this does what mid
pool is basically telling us here is
that the big secret that he's discovered
is that they're all characters being
written in a comic book but they have no
real control over themselves and that
Deadpool is the one person who's come to
realize this absolute fact and so again
as we continue with this story we pick
up with taskmaster and taskmaster is at
the home of Doctor Strange and he's
investigating and going through
and looking at what's going on here of
course again his tracking of Deadpool is
led into this location and what we learn
is that Deadpool had killed both Wong
and dr. strange by presumably
decapitating Wang and stabbing dr.
strange through the heart but as dark as
a taskmasters going through the building
he realizes that Deadpool simply didn't
just kill him arbitrarily that Deadpool
was looking for something and taskmaster
realizes what it was a Deadpool was
looking for when he comes across a book
that shows him the Nexus of all
realities indicating that Deadpool was
perhaps attending to find a way to
escape this reality with that being said
we're going to go ahead and bring this
video to an end I hope you guys enjoyed
it if you did let me know and I will
catch you guys later
ha